good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-4552
object class
safe
special containment procedures
scp-4552 is to be surrounded by a
chain-link fence two meters high and
watched by at least two armed guards at
all times test subjects assigned to
scp-4552 have authorization for access
but must notify the site director before
accessing scp-4552
and must record all activity related to
it
civilians visiting the area are
permitted to take pictures of the site
but trespassing of the chain-link fence
is strictly prohibited
no imagery of the foundation is to be
kept on site as the public may take note
of the foundation's existence all
personnel assigned to scp-4552
must be wearing an official irish army
uniform as opposed to the standard
security officer uniform
description
scp-4552
is the remains of a sandstone castle
located around 12 kilometers west of
dingle county kerry ireland this site is
officially recognized as menard castle
by the republic of ireland the ruins
consist of a rectangular tower house
constructed from roughly dressed
sandstone blocks secured by a strong
adhesive all four corners of the
castle's base were blown off during a
siege led by oliver cromwell former lord
protector of the british commonwealth
all occupants of the castle were either
killed or forced to retreat leaving the
site in a state of disrepair
the lies of those that inhabited the
castle remain mostly undiscovered to the
foundation and local historical
societies other than four diary entries
scp-4552
through scp-455204
written by a domestic servant who had
previously helped maintain the premises
see addendum 4552
1.
any personnel who enters the tower house
of
scp-4552 will begin to hallucinate a
dense fog cutting them off from the
outside world the voice of a deceased
loved one will then call out to them
often attempting to apologize or comfort
the subject if the subject hasn't lost
an acquaintance in the course of their
lifetime no hallucination will occur a
vision of the loved one will approach
the subject often placing a hand on
their shoulder or embracing them the
individual can interact with and speak
to the vision for approximately one
minute after which the vision and fog
will fade before the hallucination ends
it has always delivered the following
verse
allies have come and gone
some leave with or without choice
others remain in the world behind me
we are the same
too mournful of the past
too terrified of the future
welcome to my sandstone hell
note these hallucinations will not
activate if two or more personnel enter
scp-4552 at a time
additionally those who do not enter the
tower house are unable to see or hear
the hallucinations but can still hear
the subject within scp-4552
addendum 4552-01
the following diary entries were
recovered from within scp-4552
found in a partially rotted chest within
the castle's cellar they have been
translated from a form of monster irish
to english
scp-4552-01
today was exhausting
something appeared to be on master's
mind he seemed
distressed jumpy
the mistress was summoned by her parents
recently but she'll be back by tomorrow
evening right
apparently master had requested the
number of guards to be doubled or at
least that's what letter told me i'll be
damned if anyone here besides master
knew why
golly so much seemed off today i i
hardly know what to write about
i've also been wanting to get back into
poetry for quite some time now i was
planning on writing some this evening
but suffered taking quite a bit more
time than i was expecting
a shame
i've had puffins on my mind all day
so carefree so happy so filled with life
and joy for their brothers and sisters
quite a good subject for a poem if you
ask me
i envy puffins
arnia
scp-4552-02
tomorrow's the day
i've been meaning to tell leonard how i
felt about him for a while now
he's got to say yes right who else could
he possibly be interested in oh how i
wish we could run away from this cold
prison imagine our kids imagine our cute
little garden growing the finest herbs
in all of munster what a happy day that
will be two puffins raising their happy
little chicks
the mistress returned home today but
master still seemed so on edge i don't
have time to worry about them i'm much
too happy to bury myself in his attitude
from the borough you rise dressed in the
black of desire dressed in the white of
innocence your beak is your mighty sword
that will free us both from this
sandstone hell
or nia
scp-4552-03
hannah
hannah of all people
i didn't find her much too interesting
when i started my life here but really
funny i suppose hannah was supposed to
be our kid's name
why must you take everything from me
ornia
scp-4550
[Music]
we have been told that lord cromwell's
army is on their way
and that everyone on the estate must
hold their ground hannah is gone
i don't care anymore
death comes too soon
or maybe to some not soon enough let us
leave this world behind come along
leonard i've had enough
of our sandstone hell
ornia
addendum 4552
2.
the following test logs involving
scp-4552 were documented on o4 29 2018.
in each test a d-class personnel who had
lost at least one acquaintance during
their lifetime was told to enter
scp-4552 and report any encounters with
hallucinations
after the tests all six subjects were
offered class a traumatic amnestic
therapy and all subjects declined
scp-4552 tests one to six
test one subject d-20457
relation
wife hallucination don't let me drag you
down like this it's all right i
understand just be happy for the both of
us
okay
test two subject
d0458 relation daughter hallucination
why are you crying daddy where's mommy i
don't understand
test three
subject d-20467
relation father
hallucination house cassie don't tell me
she choked on a goldfish again good to
see you champ
come i believe we have some time
together now
test four subject two zero five five
eight relation sister
hallucination long time no see don't
worry you'll be with me and mom soon
enough
that wasn't meant to be a threat or
anything
testify
subject 20502
relation father hallucination it's been
a while hasn't it move along now the
living aren't done with you yet
note the verse repeated at the end of
the hallucination was spoken in mandarin
as opposed to english mandarin is the
subject's first language
test 6 subject
relation
hallucination it wasn't my fault it
wasn't my fault it wasn't my fault get
away from me
i thought seeing it was close to saint
patrick's day i would look at something
to do with ireland thinking that it
would be uplifting
i was clearly wrong
okay this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
slot
i would like to give a special thank you
to aletreon
zargeron
professor puffer
retalias
your local fishman
derivative
gabriel hawkins
nate the klein
lost boy
octo potato football match
hms lily
the almighty fish
sayo sciodeo dimnatus
the morrigan
karim el ashmuy
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you